Alright, so the skeleton of this code is pretty much what you've already done before,
but we're going to introduce a few other things here. First of all, we
set this caller variable to be the caller of xhrGett. Now, this is a special
thing in Javascript and what it does is, whoever ends up calling xhrGet, will be
set as this xhrGet.caller parameter, and you can grab that as necessary. Next,
we do the same thing that we've done this entire time, create a new XMLHttpRequest
and call the open method, then we check the type: if it exists, then we
set it, otherwise, we assume by default that it is just text. Now the onload
function is where things get interesting if we set a callback then we go ahead
and try and call it otherwise we don't do anything and this try catch block is
something that some of you might be familiar with. We try to do what is in this
try block here and if it fails then we catch the error and throw an exception.
Now this is basically just going to print out a whole bunch of information about
the exception. And this is where caller comes in as well. You can see that we
print out the exception. The response text and the caller just for debugging
purposes. Finally, we call xhr.send, and that's it. And if we load this up in
our browser, we can see we make both calls. The first one takes a lot less time
than the second one, since it's only JSON. We can see our output JSON in the
console. And our song starts. [MUSIC]